hey what's up on today's show we're
going to be talking about how to
navigate
this trash political climate with
friends and family who see things and
hear things differently than you do
we're going to talk about navigating
tricky parent boundaries
we're going to talk about how to heal
from trauma when your house burns down
and you lose
everything stay tuned
[Music]
hey yo i'm john and this is the dr john
deloney show
we're taking your calls about your life
your relationships
your neighborhood dilemmas your country
your world
want to help you rethink re-examine just
reimagine
simple stuff we're talking human 101
stuff that has slowly over time been
taken away from us
like our relationships our boundaries
our our
our wisdom collectively individually
we're gonna talk about love we're gonna
talk about loss we're gonna talk about
family issues infidelity finding
love again and we may talk about weird
clappers
literally clappers people who press
their hands together either too loudly
too softly leg clappers for crying out
loud
hey listen tapping your leg a few times
does not communicate
appreciation it communicates
indifference and flat-out laziness
here's the thing for about nine months
most of us haven't been in a public
setting
where there's been any sort of clapping
going on so any clapping that's
happening is happening in your house
that's super weird and you've probably
fallen out of love with certain people
certain loved ones after watching them
clap up close it's embarrassing for
everybody
so as the world is slowly starting to
start to open back up
this is a good time to practice in front
of the mirror take the time
become a good clapper get your technique
down
into terrible and indifferent clappers
you know i hate
mechanistic metaphors for people but fix
it
fix it you're embarrassing yourself fix
it
and here's the other thing back in the
60s fix the clap
i understand meant something totally
different than what we're talking about
here
but i'm i want everybody to to forget
the 60s this is
the 2020s good or bad or ugly
fix the clapping fix it all right so
whatever's going on in your home in your
heart
in your head and how you just put your
hands together
whatever i'm here to stand and walk with
you give me a call at 1-844-693-3291
that's
four four six nine three three two
nine one or you can email me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
ask john ramseysolutions.com and don't
forget
if somebody is awesome in your life um
if
if you've got a boyfriend a girlfriend a
mom dad husband wife
kid boss neighbor somebody who's going
be of
someone who's going above and beyond in
the human being category
who's just good it's just good they
weren't good and now they've turned it
around they said the words i'm sorry and
they're making a difference in their
life in your life
email me and let me know some positive
things that are going on in addition to
your questions
and we will read some of those positive
read about some of those positive folks
on the air i love it love it love it all
right let's go straight to the phones
let's see here
let's don't go there for let's go here
first let's go to john in detroit
michigan brother john how are we doing
hey doctor john i'm doing great how are
you doing
outstanding good man how is it in
michigan this morning
freezing it will be that way until we'll
be down by you
march yeah it is not everyday maybe may
oh fantastic good for you well man how
can i help this morning
yeah i just want to say i love the show
you are a great addition to the ramsey
team
so i'm i'm really enjoying what you what
you're doing there so
thank you thank you so much brother i'm
i'm having a hoot man
we're having fun hey my question is
about
uh my father-in-law okay so been married
almost 13 years i have
three amazing daughters and i want to
start by saying that my father-in-law
is a great grandpa to my kids
okay he is kind he's gentle
and they love him like crazy um
he however he's just not been a great
provider to his wife
who is disabled she receives disability
she's
unable to work and so my wife and i get
frustrated that he's not
providing it's just hard for us to
understand
and was calling to see if you had any
thoughts to
how we can best work through this very
cool so one
high five to you for for being a great
dad
high five to you for recognizing that
he's a good granddad that's cool man
sometimes when we have problems with
people we just lump them all in a big
bucket of
of suck or a big bucket of awesome and
good for you for me being able to
differentiate that
so when you say he's not a good provider
dig into that a little bit what does
that mean
yeah so he's self-employed
i would categorize him as a dreamer um
he's always seems to be like one big
deal away from
breaking out something huge so he's like
a disney character right
yeah he's almost always just really
really close right and so he's
even an optimist which i think is a
great quality but it just
those those great things don't really
seem to pan out
um we know he has business debt he has
little to no retirement
he's opted out of social security based
on past jobs he's had
um and i guess most recently just to
kind of bring you up to speed where
where we're at my wife and her brother
so there's two kids
my wife and her brother had a pretty
tough conversation with him a couple
weeks ago
about getting a different job maybe even
if it's not his
current job his dream job and he didn't
really take it well
he got pretty angry he got defensive but
he did agree to
look and then a couple weeks in
obviously nothing's really come up yet
but
i don't think it's ill will dr john it
almost feels like a
delusion like i love him around my kids
there are great christian people like
they have great
hearts it's just hard to know he's kind
of living off of
a small disability income knowing that
maybe an inheritance is going to come to
him at some point
but he doesn't seem to care about doing
that for for his kids um
so i guess last thing and then i'll i'll
stop you know
we're doing fine financially we're on
dave's plan we have been on his plan for
like 15 plus years we don't expect or
need any
inheritance from them that's not where
this is coming from it's just kind of
hard to understand
so yeah so i was going to ask you is
this a is this
burning a hole in your heart because of
a character issue or
a map is this a math problem uh are you
looking down the road and saying
we're going to end up taking care of him
and his disabled wife in the future
because he's not taking is that where
this is
headed or are you just looking at this
as a dad
and a husband and wondering what in the
world's in this dude's brain
the first part i would say is um
real and i think that my wife and i are
processing through that you know how
would we handle that if that
were to come there so how would you they
don't how's that conversation going
the conversation has gone i would say it
depends on
what happens so if if something happened
to him and we had to take care of her
mom
i think we would be much more open to it
if something happened to her and we had
to take care of him
i think that it would be harder for her
gotcha
but would you still do it
we're trying to define that line right
now okay
okay so as for what's going on with him
man who knows he would have to call lynn
and we'd have to sit down and dig into a
little bit
um everybody's got their
their own bag of tricks to try to make
themselves feel better
um he may did his wife did your
mother-in-law
did she become disabled through their
marriage or part way through their
marriage or she always had
disability challenges fairly recently
like within the last five years or so
she she um has become that disabled so
has he always struggled with provision
or is this something that's just
fallen upon him no it's it's always been
a struggle
um they've moved around a lot because of
it you know
great jobs that don't pan out so it's
kind of a
habitual thing gotcha so i'm going to
give you
maybe the best piece of advice i could
give you which is
it doesn't matter and you're gonna have
to let it go
because in in the old a.a
literature being frustrated with
somebody being angry with somebody
spending your day wondering what's in
their head is like poisoning yourself
and hoping they will die
it's just it's just serving to poison
you and your
relationship with your wife and so it's
this is who
this guy is that's who he has always
been
um like as you say he's somebody that
loves your grandkids he just doesn't
love working
and he loves your family
he's just not stepped up
and provided for his family and he i
guess he's waiting for a rainy day check
is that right is somebody going to pass
away in his life and he's going to get
an inheritance
yeah we think that's the case but you
know i
we think so yeah that hasn't been made
very clear but um
i guess the the hurt is there are people
in in his life that
sure need help yeah there's no question
about that
what you can't do is fix that and so
what you have to decide
on your end and you and your wife's end
is are you going to be the kind of
people with the character
that steps up and helps those people
even when it's somebody else's
responsibility
and honestly this is a conversation that
the whole country's having right now
right which is there's people hurting
there's people in need and there's
people saying we don't help and we do
help and it
at the end of the day i'm done with that
conversation personally
i'm just going to look for people who
need support and care in my circle
and stop blaming folks and stop whining
about it and i'm just going to
get in the middle of it and that's
really where you and your wife are
right now and where you're gonna be in
the future um he's just not gonna do it
and like you said you they had a
conversation the two people on earth who
can have a conversation which are his
two kids they did
they did their the right thing they went
to him with a challenge and went
straight up to him
and he's not going to get a job they
know that you know that but it did feel
good for them to be heard and to speak
openly
and i think that's a testament to him
it's a testament to your wife and to her
brother
but he's not gonna change that and
really you guys are gonna have to decide
from a character perspective who y'all
are gonna be and not
not care who he's gonna be um
because it's not gonna change and the
more energy you spend trying to get in
his head how are we going to fix
this how are we going to get him to be
different the more you're going to make
yourself nuts
and really what you all need to decide
is how are we going to save money
for if and when he's got to move in with
us
how are we going to save money how are
we going gonna get with her
her brother and create a plan for our
disabled mother
and where is she gonna live how's she
gonna live with us or
are we gonna put him in a home and we're
not gonna let him live with us he made
his bed and he's gonna die on the street
alone i mean
it's it's these are math problems
and we just got to sit down and solve
them and it's about your character at
this point not his character so
i know that's a frustrating answer i
wish i could just say dude you just need
to tell him this and this
this is not how that works you know what
i mean um
motley crue had a great you know i'm a
dream people are just that way dude they
just
are and they're frustrating and they
leech off people they lean on people
and often those folks love so deeply and
you want them around
they're those friends that you're always
like oh you don't have my wallet and
you're always paying for them because
you love having them there they're
hilarious they're funny
they add to the conversation they'll
show up to your house with a shovel when
you got a hole in your yard that needs
being dug
but they just won't get a job they just
won't show up on a consistent basis
every day every day every day they've
always got a scheme oh man i got these
arabian horses and they're gonna
whatever the thing is
and at the end of the day you're gonna
make yourself crazy i'm gonna say it
over and over again but
you gotta let let it go what he's trying
to do why he's trying to do it
has no bearing on you guys the fact is
you got a special needs mother-in-law
that needs support
you got a father-in-law who's draining
himself dry
are draining their their income dry that
tiny little bit they live off of
they're not going to have any for you
more than likely and he may end up
having to live with you
and so you all going to have to make
plans for that moving forward man i wish
john i had some better news for you to
start the show off but that's
that's the reality get out of his head
and get into your hearts and who you are
gonna be
um and let your kids see you guys live
into that sort of character and
and that's the best you can do all right
let's go to jessica in salt lake city
utah
jessica how's it going hello thank you
for taking my call
thank you for calling how in the world
are you
i'm doing well how about you i'm doing
so good so good
so how can i help this morning well i'm
21 and my boyfriend is 35.
all right
my um my dad is worried about it
and i'm questioning whether or not i
should continue this relationship
why are you questioning it
because i um i really care
about my family i really love my family
and i don't want to cause any problems
i'm very happy with my boyfriend we
we train for a marathon together we
serve our church together
but i also wouldn't want to cause any
problems with my family
so who do you this is not a fair
question
who do you love more your family or your
35 year old boyfriend
my family ooh good job that's a good
answer by the way and that's not a fair
question
i mostly asked that question just for my
own um just to have some fun
with my own so on my own so
what is your dad when he expresses
concern about this dude what does he say
he says things like um you know he's
eight years younger than me
and he also has a 11 year old daughter
and he'll say you know she is half your
age
i think he's worried about it because he
cares about me and it
makes me question the relationship also
and so when you question the
relationship what are the questions
going into your mind
i think about if i'm making the right
decision
by continuing the relationship
what's the rush
um and i asked that question here what's
what's like dating somebody
are you are you on sort of some sort of
decision precipice is he asking you to
marry him
are you um feeling like it's now or
never
i i don't understand you're 21 you're
you're
just a baby baby girl you're just a
beautiful baby girl and you're 21 like
you're just dating somebody having a
good time
why why do you feel discomfort at this
point
i think i feel more discomfort because
we we have been talking about future
things
um okay so it's getting more serious
yes gotcha and so
here's the thing your dad's gonna
struggle with you being his child
versus you being a 21 year old adult
that's normal dad's loving their
daughters dads loving their sons
moms loving their sons moms and sons are
sometimes the worst but
moms and their daughters you're 21 and
so you're in that wackadoo area
where your dad still looks at you as
though you're 13 you think you're 47
and neither of those things are true
right the other side of it is you're
going to struggle with taking anyone's
wisdom because you're 21
and you think you're super smart and
you've got it all figured out
and you love him and he's so cute and he
loves god
and he loves running and he's such a
good dad all those things right that
make you feel good
and so um if you like this guy and you
like hanging out with him i say keep
hanging out with him
if you value your dad's opinion then
break up with him
and so when i say either of those things
what do you feel
i feel like i value my dad's opinion
more
why is that
because i feel like he
i don't know he's the first boyfriend
i've had and i'm
just kind of i feel like i don't really
need to be dating anyone right now
sir are you calling me with permission
to break up with him
no okay are you calling me with
permission to tell your dad hey i'm 21
and i like a guy and it's a little
unconventional and y'all are old enough
to be buddies but
shake it off i like this dude and we're
just seeing where it goes
are you calling me permission for that
i will yes i would like to see where it
goes okay
so distill all of your the the thoughts
in your mind
the whose side are you on what team are
you on to distill that down into a
single question for me
um
i want to respect my dad's decisions
also
finding out where this relationship can
go
sure this dude's 35 has he ever taken
your dad out for a drink or for coffee
and just hung out and said hey
here's my intentions with dating your
daughter have they ever just
met together he hasn't
why not um
my boyfriend hasn't invited him to do
anything like that and my dad hasn't
either
hmm so here's what i would recommend
number one
you're a grown-up you can do what you
want to do
at some point you're gonna have wishes
about your life
whether it's having kids whether it's
naming your child whether it's moving
away out of utah
to arkansas or to florida or to ireland
there's gonna be things that come up in
your adult life that your dad has an
opinion on
that you're gonna disagree with him and
so you're gonna have to start drawing
boundaries
and respect your dad obviously if he's a
good guy you seem to love him and
he cares about you and you get that
but then at some point you're gonna have
to make your own decisions and
as a as an adult the other side of that
is i just hear in your voice that you
maybe think he's right on this one and
maybe you really like this guy it's cool
but maybe dad's right and so i
i still get wisdom from my old man i
don't do everything that he tells me in
fact i do very little of what he tells
me but i value his opinion greatly
because he's seen things
and he understands things and he just
got a different world view than i do and
i like collecting different world views
um my suggestion is if this guy really
likes you he needs to take your dad out
they need to go get a drink somewhere go
grab a beer go grab some coffee
and just get to know each other and let
your dad ask him all the hard questions
your dad i promise you has had a million
fake conversations with this guy
if i just get him uh they've already had
these conversations over and over again
in his head just not in real life
and your boyfriend may have had these
conversations with him
if he really is invested in you he's
going to be invested in your family
because you marry the whole thing
and so i recommend he be a grown man
he's 35 years old take your dad out go
hang out and get to know each other and
then they can have that conversation he
may come back to you and be like hey by
the way we're breaking up i don't like
you anymore
after meeting with your dad or your dad
may come back and say hey
this is weird he's 14 15 years older
than you
it's not it doesn't make me comfortable
but if that's who you like that's who
you like
and dad's gonna have to deal but at the
end of the day
you're 21 you're an adult by all
legal definitions not psychologically
but you're an adult
and at the end you're going to start
making adult decisions and some of those
decisions are going to make your dad
uncomfortable
and you're going to be okay with that
but you've got my permission to do
whatever you want to do if he's a good
guy and he treats you well
and you are safe and you are having fun
with life then
keep dating him and if you think this
isn't a good idea my dad's got my best
interest at heart and man
i should listen to my old man then break
up with him or
just be 21 and enjoy your life have fun
it's a little bit different he's got a
11 year old daughter
um and so there's a little more pressure
there as some as you're dating somebody
but man
don't you're 21 years old you're a kid
and i don't mean that mean but you're a
kid enjoy your life
enjoy your life okay thank you so much
for the call jessica all right let's go
to
miranda in los angeles california how in
the world are you
i'm good um i just as you know
california's kind of crazy right now
with like
everything political going on and i just
wanted to call and ask you like
hold on miranda hold on miranda i have
no idea what you're talking about
california's crazy
just kidding just kidding yeah it feels
like a zoo it feels like an absolute zoo
yes it's you know and yeah that's why i
think i'm calling to because i just like
i know the election's almost over
but um i think just i'm 21 years old and
i was
born and raised in california and so and
i am christian
um so i do lean more towards the
conservative side
but i think i was just calling because i
want to ask like how do i navigate
through this like
and i've been having a lot of healthy
conversations with people but i i've
been having some hard conversations too
with people who
don't necessarily agree with me and that
is totally fine
but i just want to know like how do i
talk to people who just don't want to
hear it at all or who don't want to sit
down with adults
and talk about like our differences oh
you're not going to like my answer but
you just don't
yeah people if people don't want to talk
to you if they don't have any interest
in being friends with somebody that
thinks differently than
they do or has different experiences
than they do
then you just you brush your shoulders
off and you bounce
you know what i mean like it's you're
just gonna end up beating your head up
against the wall
give me an example of something that's
happened like that
well um so uh you i i'm very open person
like even though i am christian and
conservative i'm like hey like i want to
hear you i want to talk with you so i'll
sit down with somebody
and we'll talk about it um but recently
one of my family
members has gotten offended by
my political view and i know a lot of
people don't agree with me but
uh like our president i don't agree with
everything he says but i do like his
views i do like his policies so i
lean more towards him okay and so i was
trying to tell my cousin hey like
i like him because of this and i was
giving her good evidence like policies
you know
and she's like i don't want to hear it
and she called me
a white supremacist and i was like oh
like
i am not that at all like i just like
the way he thinks like i like what he's
doing you know
and she happens to also be
african-american
and mexican so she kind of got offended
and said that
like i feel certain way towards african
american community and i don't at all
so i think that was a hard conversation
and she hasn't talked to me so i was
like
okay so i just kind of left it alone
sure well yeah that's an example
so i think it's i think it's important
that at the end of the day all you can
control is you
and yeah a a
way that i have adopted navigating the
world and this is new for me this is
just a few years old and
it's it's given me so much more empathy
for the world and so much more peace in
my life
and really i think made me a better dad
and a better husband and a better
community member
which is remembering that everyone
around me
everyone is fighting a secret battle
every day
people have hurts in their hearts and
their minds that i will never see
i will never experience i will never
know
and so when somebody says something like
you're a white supremacist
and you're thinking no i'm not then
you can do one of two things you can
choose to go to war with that person
and put a stick in the ground and say
i'm going to die on this hill
or you can say man that person has
some experiences that i don't understand
that person's hurting
and i know that i'm not but i also know
that
going to war with somebody doesn't
change their heart it just ends with a
couple of bodies on the ground
and so instead of going to war i'm just
going to love that person
or maybe once the smoke clears on that
particular argument i'm going to circle
back and say hey walk me through what
you meant by white supremacists because
i don't see myself that way
and does that make sense and i know
we're talking about an egregious thing
here but
um these kind of conversations have been
going on for years and years and years
and they feel like they're in an apex
they're probably not
but everything feels so divisive
everything
from what car you drive and where you
live and and what you
wear and what you listen to all of it
has become so
divisive and so trying to solve what's
in the heart and mind of somebody else
you just can't do
you are more than entitled to your
beliefs and your opinions
that's what this great country's founded
on right
and yeah that comes with the the
understanding that she does too
and other people can choose to not like
you that's totally fair
it hurts but it's totally fair other
people can choose to say your beliefs
make you fill in the blank
they may not be true they may not um
represent what's in your heart and mind
but
we're in a place where people have free
speech and they're allowed to do that
too we've reached this
madness apex where we're trying to
control what other people think and what
they say
and it's just gotten insane it's gotten
nuts right
and so at the end of the day you can
just control you
and the best thing you can do for the
folks around you is just to respond in
love
right that's that's that's the
that's the lever you've got or you
respond with a hammer and i'll just tell
you
people who respond with hammers often
look like idiots
they don't solve the problem they just
make it worse right they just bring
gasoline to a
a fireworks show right it just doesn't
make any sense
and so yeah um be open to listening to
other people's
perspectives invite other perspectives
into your heart and mind i think that's
so important man
and if someone doesn't want to be your
friend they don't be your friend
right yeah absolutely i think i just had
a hard time with it too because she is
older than me
she's someone i've like looked to like
for her experiences because she's a hard
worker she has a degree
like she has done great for herself but
just a certain decision she's made in
her life
i just don't agree with and that's okay
you know and i've invited her to look
into the bible and talk with her and sit
with her
and even when she was being rude to me
like over
like text message all i kept saying was
i love her you know sure but
i just think like in that situation it
was fine like i
didn't really hurt me but i was just
like disappointed you know yeah and i
think when someone's attacking you and
you're trying to like say you love them
it's like wait what
well you just you brought forth a really
important
point having any sort i want everyone
listening this to hear this
having any sort of of
delicate nuanced or even
angry conversation any sort of robust
dialogue back and forth
over text message is clinically insane
it's just ridiculous and dumb and stupid
and
pointless and idiotic and i'm trying to
think of all the words i can
just writing off top of my head it's
just madness
don't do it right call somebody on the
phone
if you want to talk politics call them
on the phone or sit with them in person
and if you're in los angeles i think you
probably have to be outside
with a hazmat suit on whatever that
looks like for you but
but have that conversation in person
have it in person
yeah don't do it in text because here's
why she may have been laughing the whole
time
she may absolutely know you're not a
white supremacist and she's texting that
because she's just trying to be funny
and you heard it in a way that hurts now
maybe not probably not but
when you you lose all context when you
just strip it away with
with thumbs and zeros and ones zeros and
ones zeros and ones right
um yeah yeah don't say those you were
shouting profanity at me
oh there's always that too right right
so clearly she may have been
um been upset but yeah
so much of that is mitigated when you
have in-person conversations when two
people who disagree are sitting around a
table when two people are sitting around
a blanket in a in a
in a park somewhere two people are going
for a walk together
that's when you have real conversations
that's why the digital interactions have
just
jumped a shark they're not even real
anymore it's insanity
so yeah i i would with all of my heart
and mind and soul
miranda i'd recommend you call her
say hey let's have a conversation in
person i'd love to get together i'll buy
the coffee
um i don't even know if you're allowed
to drink coffee in california anymore um
but if you are
i'm just kidding i'm just being
ridiculous um but yeah grab coffee and
y'all get together
and then talk about these differences
and say hey you said this
and walk me through what you meant by
that and let them explain
if you call somebody to have coffee and
you're just ready geared up you have all
these imaginary
ugly conversations and you're like yeah
yeah yeah and then i'm gonna tell her
this and i'm gonna tell her this
man then you're going in there for a
fight she'll feel it she'll respond with
a fight and that meeting will be
completely useless and pointless
so all you can control is you when
somebody doesn't agree with you
somebody has a different opinion than
you you can control you and so just
assume that other people have different
experiences than you
different perspectives don't assume
everyone around you is dumb
i've got a group of guys right now that
i've known for years and years and years
and we have some text threads that we
exchange we've got some articles that we
go back and forth
it's michael and kevin two guys that i
love and they i give permission to speak
into my life
and we disagree on a lot of stuff but i
also know
beneath those disagreements those are
two guys that love their families they
love their country they love their
neighborhood they love their church they
love
the least of these in their communities
and they work really really hard at
their jobs they're good solid men
and that means we're anchored in and now
we can rappel off the side in
an exchange of ideas and exchange of
disagreements
and we're all going to do that safely
and we're all going to do that
with character and with love and i also
want to challenge everybody to do this
you only learn from people who have
different ideas than you
and if you just seek a constant stream
of confirmation about what you already
believe
about what you already think you know
you are not
stretching yourself you are not learning
it's like going to the gym
and lifting weights that you know you
can already lift you're never going to
get stronger
you're never going to get in better
shape you're never going to get more fit
you're just going to become this echo
chamber
of opinions that don't go anywhere
so here's a couple of my rules rule
number one
have friends that think differently than
you do have friends that look
differently than you do
have friends and i'm not talking about
acquaintances i'm talking about close
friends that sit at your table
that live differently than you because
you're going to find out that most of
the time there's a
shared humanity that is much greater
than any difference you're going to have
much much greater you're also going to
realize that some of your opinions that
you hold so tight and so dear to
are wrong they're just incorrect
and sometimes if you're like me you're
gonna have to look backwards at a
wake of people that you have hurt over
the years or you've given incorrect
information to over the years
and you're going to have to apologize in
your heart if you still know those
people you're going to apologize to them
and you have to work really hard to do
better
you have to really really hard to do
better
maya angelou says do the best you can
and then when you know more
then go do better and the only way you
can know more is by being around people
who think differently than you do
the second thing is read different
things
read books that challenge you if you are
entrenched in this position
find a book find not articles because
those can be nonsensical sometimes
find books can too but find respected
literature find fiction find things that
make you uncomfortable politically
ideologically and read them read them
and some of it is drivel some of it is
just nonsense it's just
vomit on old sheets of paper
right but some of it really will
challenge you and will cause you to go
back to your original sources
so if you're a person of faith whatever
your faith trajectory is
it's going to go back to your whether
it's the bible or the quran you have to
look at that and say
hmm i i thought this the scientist is
saying this this author gives a
compelling argument
let me go back and see if i read this
wrong or if i felt this wrong i'm going
to go back and call people
i meet with one or two people every
single week
and say hey i had these thoughts this
week i don't know if they're right
you're wise you've you're studied in
these areas
let's dig in but the point is i
intentionally put myself
with ideas that i don't agree with that
are different for me
because that's the only way i'm gonna
learn that's why when i go to the gym
at my house i constantly am adding
heavier weight so i can get stronger
i'm constantly looking up wackier
workout programs so that i can
get more limber my body can move better
as i get older
i'm constantly trying to find people who
are parenting better than me who are
being better husbands than me i want to
surround myself with people who do
things different so i can grow
you've got to do that too get out of the
echo chambers in our phones
our news cycles our digital media
it's built to give us just the things
that we already think
so you've got to be intentional about
reading things that you disagree with
about listening to things you disagree
with about reading
about being around people you disagree
with and you're going to find yourself a
more robust person
trust me just do it
do it do it do it and make sure you seek
wise counsel because
when you are not a person of ideas
little gk chesters and quote
when you're not a person of ideas any
new idea sound sexy and cool and like
whew let's go jump into this one right
um man there's so many when it comes to
diet and nutrition
and climate there's all oh it's going to
be this and everybody just jumps off
this and then the scientists are like
hey
that's not really accurate we're over
here so have wise people
right have wise people who are learned
they know what they're talking about
and not somebody who just reads a couple
of editorials or a couple of
click bait things on yahoo news or
whatever but be around wise people who
think differently than you i'm going to
quit ranting on that because i talk
about that all day
all right let's go to let's see here
let's
yeah we got time for one more call let's
go to michelle in san francisco
michelle good morning good morning how
are you
oh great how are you i am so good
and you guys have been through the
absolute ringer out there the past few
months
how's it been well yeah that's why i'm
calling it
okay um actually yeah i live
up in the um the napa valley and my
cottage burns
no i'm so sorry yeah
yuck so you lost everything huh
correct i did now the good news is from
a financial perspective i'm okay i had
renters insurance
okay emergency fund and all that stuff
but um i'm pretty stressed out
still yes staying at a hotel in napa
but i'm still kind of going through
um especially when there's we continue
to have fire
danger here so during those weather
events i'm very stressed
out so just reaching out about that so
you do me a huge favor yeah
i want you to when we hang up this phone
i want you to close
close your eyes and take it as deep a
breath as you can and hold it first
like a count of one a count of two a
kind of three and then let it out
yeah and then just say yeah thank you
body for trying to take care of me
because that stress you feel that
panicky
anxiousness is your body saying
whoa we just went through a major trauma
that trauma is still happening all
around us we should probably get out of
here and go to kansas
right and right the other part of your
brain is like we like napa valley it's
beautiful here when it's not on fire we
have our friends and our community here
we're not going to kansas but there is a
part of your brain that's telling you to
run
right you've heard the fight fighter
freeze and it's telling you to get out
of here get out of here get out of here
and it's just doing what it's supposed
to do um when you
when your cottage caught fire was were
you guys part of
you know the hanging on hanging on and
then all of a sudden you got to be out
of here in 30 minutes and
go to the next place and then you're at
a shelter and then you got to go to the
next place in the next place
was it were you in one of those caravans
correct yeah like i
i actually the fire started just a few
miles from my place so i actually saw
the fire start
and then i would evacuate to the next
place and then the fire would go there
and then i would evacuate to the next
place and the fire would go there so
it took a few evacuations to get me to a
place where
there was no fire yeah and so this
so understand i'm going to unpack this
with you understand
the depth of the trauma you experienced
okay
few things are as important to us as our
home
even a rented home that's our dwelling
that's our safe place that's when our
body
our shoulders automatically drop when we
walk in that door and
you had what i would call a full assault
trauma which
and that's not a clinical term i just
made that up but you got to see it
you got to smell it when fire is like
that if you've never been around them
before to the other listeners of this
podcast
you can hear it right everyone's yelling
there's sirens there's flashing lights
every sensory overload you could
experience you did
right and then you went to a safe place
that suddenly wasn't safe in a safe
place it wasn't safe and you just kept
running running running
i want you to cut yourself some slack
you're gonna have to
reconnect with your body over over time
okay i think you're gonna be okay
i really do most people most of the time
their body and their hearts and minds
and their communities they all heal
together
okay so rest in that but that
anxiousness that unease
that is totally totally normal that's
your heart and mind trying to take care
of you
and thankfully it works in you it's
annoying but thankfully it works for you
okay um here's a couple of things i
would recommend
do you have a community there in napa
yeah i've got some great friends who
have been super supportive oh that's the
family i work for
um who owns a winery they've been super
supportive so that's so cool
okay so i want you to get a group of
people together
when is it when does the fire season
slow down is it the next month or so
correct yeah probably in 30 days okay
yeah
so let's pick a time right before
thanksgiving or between thanksgiving and
christmas
and i want you to get a group of people
together that you love
and that you trust and i want you to
have a funeral for your house
okay interesting i want you to have an
act an actual ceremony
whether you've saved some stuff whether
you were able to go back to the wreckage
and you went through it and you got some
old sticks or something
i want you to have a funeral for what
you lost and what that's going to do
for you but more importantly for your
body is going to give you a touchstone
it's going to give you a period at the
end of that sentence
and from that you're going to be able to
begin to to heal
and grow to whatever is going to come
next but until you have appeared at the
end of that sentence
you're going to have that low level burn
of anxiety that never stops
when people experience human tragedy
like they lose a loved one they lose a
child
it's so hard to have this you have the
funeral but it's so hard to have the
actual
closure moment because it's saying
goodbye and we
so don't want to say goodbye to those
that we love and so what you're going to
have to do is say goodbye and you got to
do that in a community
okay you got to have people around you
that you love that you can be sad
together you can be scared together
and then beautifully you're going to
rebuild together too
and then uh expect this my buddy um
two of my dearest friends on in the
world eric and danielle they
ex they were in the the nashville
tornadoes back in march right before
covet hit which seems like a thousand
years ago
their homes being rebuilt now and
uh eric has talked about walking through
as they're rebuilding the house
and he just burst into tears and there's
a phenomenal book on trauma called the
body keeps the score
by bessel vander kulk we'll link to it
in the show notes
but it talks about trauma pockets itself
away in the corners of your heart and
your mind and your body
and your feet and your legs and your
back all kind of weird places
and that's not woo-woo that's actual
science but expect over the next
year of the next two years you're just
gonna have
big exhales and you're gonna have
moments when you're just walking and all
of a sudden you start crying and you
don't know why
you're gonna walk into your new rent
home and it's gonna be safe and
beautiful and you're gonna see your
closet you're just bursting into tears
you're not gonna know why
be graceful with my friend michelle okay
that's just you healing
and don't over expect too much from
yourself right now you're right smack in
the middle of it
fires are still burning right you're
still in it and
just trust yourself and know that you're
loved man and i'm so glad you have good
friends that's so cool
so cool that you guys oh yeah wonderful
wonderful people yeah
well thank you so much i so appreciate
it no thank you for calling me and for
trusting me i
absolutely am heartbroken that you lost
everything that sucks
absolutely sucks losing your home is so
devastating it's so
it's ultra traumatic um
but thank you for trusting me with with
what your next wobbly crooked step
is going to be but honor yourself know
that your your brain's just trying to
take care of you
it's continues to smell danger and see
danger and feel danger
and you felt danger at its most visceral
sense you lost everything
and then that felt like that fire was
coming from you um
and then get hold a funeral for what you
lost an actual ceremony for what you
lost and then do it with friends and
then just give yourself grace over the
next six months next year next two years
as you heal from this
and that healing is gonna come all over
you in all kinds of weird places
um and make sure you've got people
around you that's awesome michelle we
are rooting for
you and your whole community as you all
rebuild as you come back together
and um you build a future together so as
we wrap up today's show
want to end it with ah man
i i feel like i've lied every show up
until now
this is the best this is the best this
ladies and gentlemen
this is the single greatest artist of
all time
she produced one masterpiece she was on
several other masterpieces but she
produced one
masterpiece and she squeaked it in
just under the wire right before the
turn of the century
right before everything just started
falling apart in the late 1990s in 1998
on her unbelievable world-class
greatest record of all time the
miseducation of lauryn hill
lauren hill opens the record with a
extraordinary track lost ones
and in that in that poetic masterpiece
she
she says the following
now now how come your talk turned cold
gained the whole world for the price of
your soul trying to grab
hold of what you can't control now
you're all floss what a sight to behold
wisdom is better than silver and gold i
was hopeless
now i'm on hope road every man want to
act like he's exempt
need to get down on his knees and repent
can't slick talk on a day of judgment
your movement similar to a serpent what
tried to play straight how's your whole
how your whole style bent
consequence is no coincidence hypocrites
always want to play innocent
ladies and gentlemen that is the one and
only miss lauren hill and this
is the dr john deloney show
[Music]